okay let's talk by the way someone's
saying you have to pay me to get me to
talk about cory booker not true i'm
going to talk about cory booker right
now i haven't talked that much about
cory booker recently because people
haven't paid obviously and about the
fact that he's running for president
other than to say i don't find him to be
super genuine he strikes me more than
other politicians more than the average
politician as someone who says
everything he says is extra calculated
and less genuine than other politicians
and that says a lot because we're
talking about politicians here and I was
watching this interview he did yesterday
I believe it was or maybe the day before
with MSNBC's Chris Matthews he didn't
even answer a simple question about
whether football is dangerous like the
sport of American football and whether
he would let his kids play cory booker
played football in college okay and
Chris Matthews asked a very sensible
question which is we know about the
dangers of football now it's not just
concussions but it's the long-term brain
injury CTE it's found not just in
players who play professionally but it's
it's we're seeing it in college players
there are now even some instances of
players who only played in high school
and were killed and there was evidence
of CTE chronic traumatic encephalopathy
in them truly disabling brain injuries
and the growing consensus that football
is just not safe something's very wrong
so Chris Matthews asked Booker about it
Booker first punts with a joke about a
4.0 4.0 yards per carry or GPA and 1600
receiving yards or something and then
names football coaches of his and then
Chris Matthews asks again and Cory
Booker mentions Notre Dame take a look
at this the NFL would you encourage kids
today parents with kids young teenagers
to play football I would be a hypocrite
I got into the Stanford because of a 4.0
1600 4.0 yards per carry 1600
[Laughter]
but you played for a really great school
and I played for some great coaches like
Danny Green I saw we're going to show
they get you some of your highlights on
the show tonight
and 81 yeah and I would say asking you
you get a reception a college football
at the Stanford level national
competition yeah and you catch that ball
right that aside what the ball you got
it and then somebody whacks you can't
brings you down on the gravel with all
their might it's football too dangerous
but listen up Notre Dame we played
against in South Bend and you know I was
rooting for ya let me ask you again is
it dangerous well you know once I played
against Notre Dame why is this such a
difficult question it is their video
later in the interview where Booker does
answer the question I wasn't able to
find it anywhere these are not
complicated questions like I get that
there are more serious issues than
football but why not just say hey you
know what I played football but at the
time we didn't know everything that we
know now and yeah I would be hesitant to
let my kids or to encourage other kids
to play football or whatever is it that
like is he that worried Pat about
offending colleges who make a ton of
money off of college football programs
like why can't he just answer well he
definitely is a very calculating
politician and he hasn't prepared for
this question I suppose he's in a pickle
here because if he says that he does
support kids playing football then it
sounds like he's being insensitive to
CTE and if he says that he supports you
know kids not playing football or
completely changing the rules and the
safety measures then he sounds like
unamerican and he's against one of our
national pastimes but at the end of the
day it's not like this is a voting issue
people aren't going to prioritize this
just give your honest opinion yeah I I
truly don't get it and I'm not a big
Booker guy on a lot of issues I agree
with him that's not super controversial
I agree with most Democratic candidates
on lots of issues I do find Booker's
idea of these enterprise zones the idea
is to fix areas of urban blight urban
areas that are struggling
with total free-market Enterprise Zones
and he got that he got it or that an
idea originates with right-wing
supply-side or Jack Kemp I just disagree
that that's the way to solve the
problems happening in urban areas Booker
has talked about fueling the tech sector
by easing regulations on big tech I
think the last two years have shown us
pretty clearly that the last thing we
need is fewer regulations on big tech so
I'm not a big Booker guy he's currently
polling around 6% certainly at this
point in time that you know March of the
year before the primary that could be
enough to catapult him to the nomination
still very much in the running if
history tells us anything although he is
not one of my top three or even really
top five candidates probably not coming
as a surprise to most people in the
audience one of our sponsors today is
minds.com minds is a social networking
platform that combines many features
that are similar to what you find on
platforms like YouTube or Facebook or
Twitter like news feeds groups videos
blogging except what makes Minds
different is their goal of maintaining
free speech transparency user privacy
and ensuring that users are fairly
compensated for the content they create
this has been an issue for the David
Pakman show most other major social
networking companies are secretive about
their algorithms all of the code that
drives the minds social network is free
and it's open source anybody can access
it and see how the platform operates and
contribute to the project they're sort
of taking the same open-source
principles behind something like
Wikipedia where everything is totally
open and transparent and instead
applying it to social media where you
usually don't see it they also have a
very free speech oriented content policy
everything on the site is encrypted your
data stays safe mine's doesn't track
what you're doing online the way many
other platforms do lots of other sites
give you privacy settings but that
doesn't change the fact that they still
have access to your private data
but with the encryption on mines mines
doesn't even have the ability to read
your private messages or whatever else
you're doing and every time you do
something on mines like post content or
share or like someone else's content you
earn mines tokens which can then be used
to boost the visibility of the content
that you create and post I encourage you
to go check it out at minds.com there's
also a mobile app and you can actually
follow the david pakman show on mines at
minds.com slash david pakman show I've
also put a link right underneath this
video